j'ai eu cette idée de la vie parfaite que
j'ai eue de ta mère c'est vraiment tout ce
que je voulais c'est surprenant à quel point nous sommes tous faibles
quand nous sommes convaincus que nous ne le sommes pas
c'est ce que je sais je suis dans une pièce avec
deux détectives qui traitent  moi comme si
j'étais un suspect
vous avez toujours vu les choses si clairement
comment pouvez-vous voir cela maintenant pensiez-vous
qu'il était capable la cinétique vient du jambon
vous devez rester à l'écart de ma femme votre
fille n'est pas un bon nombre de respectueux des lois
les gens qui fonctionnent bien ont la
capacité de casser tu penses que tu peux
gérer tout c'est plus grand que
toi exactement comment nous pensons que je suis
toi